comme chaque 1er de l'an affluence chez
ce photographe de cayenne on y vient
pour se faire tirer le portrait mais
aussi pour y délivrer ses voeux la
tendance cette année plus de sécurité
une façon de constituer de vos albums
souvenirs et de voir au fil disant
grandir les enfants
l'occasion aussi de souhaiter ses voeux
pour la nouvelle année
viviane ne fait que rêver beaucoup de
bonheur et de prospérité comme on veut
pour 2007
beaucoup de sécurité dans notre pays à
tout le monde beaucoup d'amour beaucoup
de bonheur et beaucoup de prospérité
dehors ce petit là ont déjà fait leurs
photos très heureux de toutes ces
festivités de sécurité pour nous et
beaucoup d'amour pour tout le monde te
plaît à terre la guyane chanter autre
rendez vous incontournable du 1er
janvier
le fleuriste ici on choisit des bouquets
pour les offrir
et l'on fait deal pour l'aiguiller pour
la guyane tout d'abord j'aimerais qu'ils
aient vraiment du changement côté
urbanisme et puis sécurité parce que on
sait déjà comment ça se présente partout
dans le monde
courage aux forces de l'ordre aux
pompiers et puis tous ceux qui oeuvrent
pour cela